de nos jours la passion du tennis
transforme en une véritable fièvre
blanche
les organisateurs de roland garros pense
qu'à la fin de la quinzaine il sera venu
250 spectateurs mais tout succès ah si
j'ose dire son revers et déjà l'on
déplore le comportement d'un nouveau
public qui contrairement à ceux qui
l'ont précédé a pris l'habitude de
manifester et de siffler un reportage
d'alain tenait si l'on en croit la
rumeur cette année l'écart s'est
accentué entre la mondaine tribune
présidentielle avec ses applaudissements
feutrée ces habitués célèbre bref son
tennis un peu parfumée hélas trop
indisciplinés tribune des le poulailler
de roland garros vivier de ces nouveaux
aficionado du tmx
réellement c'est un succès énorme même
plus que le rugby est que le football je
revenais j'étais hier avec toi il y
aurait au moins 25 contre ambri le
perdre mais je connais pas les
mécaniques alors calculer votre sport
favori et une similitude entre
notre mot ce faire vous retrouver au
parc des princes et celle du de roland
garros par exemple je pense
deux cent cinquante mille passionnés
sont attendus et sur le nombre de public
la rencontre de l'ancien et du moderne
deux conceptions de récupération
différentes aussi d'un sport spectacle
la recette qui attire de plus en plus de
monde et de moins en moins de
connaisseurs tient également peut-être
au comportement des joueurs qui a
également changé
j'ai l'impression que dans le temps faim
du joueur contesté - les balles les
points et comme ils contestent fameux
repas chacun participe aux cigales
public que les joueurs ça crée une
ambiance qui est pas toujours très
sympathique évidemment peu sympathique
caujolle sera de cet avis le nouveau
public l'a abandonné et sifflé au moment
où tu pouvais battre kaunas peu
sympathique aussi à l'égard des arbitres
abondamment conspué et qui partagent ici
l'opinion de noah sympathique enfants
aux yeux de nastase lequel
paradoxalement est le joueur qui peut se
vanter d'avoir été le plus siffler au
cours de sa carrière
je crois que le public doit participer
doit me paie l'argent et il veut créer
un doigt
manifester ses sentiments je trouve que
le tennis déjà et c'est très ennuyeux
comme ce pôle
et si on participe à c'est pas bien il
faut avoir de l'atmosphère
c'est une autre